pour salut tout le monde salue twitch
salue les mecs
donc du coup on démarre le script
initale avant soit effet que tout marche
mieux attributs talent avance ces gens
qui regardent henry pleyben avant ça un
petit peu quand on voit que le truc soit
bien lancé qu'on vérifie tranquille
ouvre un peu joué contre eux contre les
spectateurs aujourd'hui on va on va le
refaire je suis en plus chaud pour le
faire en ce moment je sais que vous
aimez bien donc pourquoi pas alors pas
forcément en mode pédagogie en mode
plutôt en mode brutale en mode brutal on
va brutalisé on va essayer de faire des
trucs jolie des jolies tactique des
machins donc on va être plus être dans
cet esprit là ça faut le savoir
donc le stream acheminera en direct plus
être dans cet esprit là en espérant que
soit sûr je fais comme tu es ce qui a
bien aidé en ce moment ci à bienne en
même temps on va être un peu dans le
caca on va voir on va voir mais
normalement non elle sera pas sûr
surtout chaînes tv et on devrait on
devrait arriver on devrait arriver
dessus d'un instant à l'autre
on va récupérer nos adversaires d'ici on
va se mettre le hosting on va se mettre
bien je regarde un peu les tchats s'il
ya des gens qui écrivent dans les
personnes qui écrit en tant mieux j'ai
envie de dire
donc j'en attends donc tout ça se passe
et ce qu'on se fait et ce qu'on soit un
petit but l'aide pour se tester la
nouvelle souris and bear qui écrit you
moi je dis le temps que les gens
arrivent on va se tester la nouvelle
souris en boulettes parce qu'on va en
avoir besoin
on va en avoir besoin dans l'aréna dans
l'aréna à venir je vais juste vérifier
mais j'étais sûr que ça allait des
cadres et je vais lui faire un coup pour
pas qu'ils partent et on va recadrer ça
comme ça et on va se tester la nouvelle
souris quand même sur hank de boules est
mulâtre ont commencé avec du retard et
en bleu quelque part ça permet ça va
vraiment permettre de faire un vrai test
grandeur nature auquel on a un pion -
mais on va on va envoyer les envoyer les
chevaux quoi envoyer la cavalerie
à
[Musique]
je tiens encore trouvé comment mater ce
qui nous avait si simple surtout contre
un hurricane à la dame prend g4
ont commencé avec du retard nous a coûté
cher bon on va en faire une vraie place
était pas une il est quoi
je suis pas chaud en bullet en ce moment
faut l'admettre
une petite position tranquille mais vous
inquiétez pas un simple à une soirée de
bullet et justes en attend que les gens
arrivent enfin vous inquiétez pas
tremblé sur la lunette c'est juste en
attendant les gens arrivent un peu
peut-être que je fasse 5 et voilà ça a
passé
j'ai juste fait re 5 pour faire cavalier
ou quatre mais là ça va pas c'est nickel
à
ah ok
on va gérer un
on va gérer le roi facile
gérer facile contre on lâche 4 on va
faire des huit dames jouent pas très
vite une nouvelle fois je vous trouve
facile là donc il va en faire une
dernière comme ça on aura fini notre
test et on va y aller on va faire les
ponts va attendre les défis on va
revenir
or aucun rajout avec ses 5 donc elle va
tout est changé je d'état jouer c'est
ses positions mais bon et solide
ça va le faire ça va on sait bien
recroquevillé là c'est bon on s'est
recroquevillé en mode on s'est
recroquevillé en mode je cherche mais
moi en fait tu vois mon train de
m'entraîner là pour la peine
du coup ça j'aime pas et va y avoir un
échec non quand on va revenir ça c'est
cool moyen de pièces sur l'échiquier
plus je vais y voir clair
je vais essayer de faire le skill pour
le faire tomber
ok on va se débarrasser du pion h ou pas
je pousse je pousse bah merde
ok on va tester le la souris du coup
ok pour la souris agréable la souris
agréable pour jouer vite vers une
amélioration où il est un peu en sueur
parce qu'on l'a flag mais bon le match
n'a qu'à oui fans c'est cette nuit ça 1h
du mat mais qui sera pas commenter en
direct ce que c'est trop tard et j'ai
envie de dormir
donc on lamine mc en sueur du coup il a
refusé le défi mais on a pu tester notre
souris donc c'était c'est vraiment
l'objectif j'avais vraiment envie de
tester la souris et voilà c'était le
petit objet que cette cette intro et
maintenant on va prendre les défis des
spectateurs donc si vous êtes là il
voulait des défis pas des fumoirs
sinon je le ferai quelques bulles est en
attendant pamela les deux matches n'a
qu'à uri fans et sony sont bien trop
tard les mails sont 1h du mat
c'est trop tard
faut dormir la nuit ici
norman attend vos défis est toujours là
oui kevin fait des stream pédagogique
quoi on ne sera pas pédagogique mais
c'est vous défoncer mais à l'avs depuis
thiès comme rennes gaubert live de
peaches comme exacts exact exact live
depuis suez comme c'est tout à fait ça
j'ai eu faim ce qyi à stream pendant
great chiukepo moi je peux même te dire
avec qui ce sera streamé d'ailleurs
alors elle veut contre team femmes
touchent en premier
dix minutes samedi 2h du mat plus tôt
après celle ci se soit 2 heures du matin
j'ai pas regardé exactement 1 6 et 1h du
mat ou 2h du mat
mais allez on va se faire plaisir on va
mettre les pions au centre donc je sais
pas exactement c'est une heure ou deux
heures du mat mais dans tous les cas
c'est bien trop tôt quoi ou tard donc on
va lui donner un pion et on va se marrer
on est là pour rigoler 1 ce soir on joue
contre les spectateurs on essaie de
faire des jolies tactique on va espérer
fouler cinq dames à 5
et voilà au lait une pièce une pièce
pour kevin numéro un fou b5 d'arrêt 5
pas de chance le petit chipeau classique
l'échec double attaque
c'est pas la première fois que vous le
voyez aïe aïe aïe team tatum qui était
chaud pour sa partie de dix minutes et
qui s'écrase après après 40 secondes
allégé bed in août à toulon sueur dans
le chat en sueur il en peut plus
bah ouais mais j'y peux rien ton point
allez on va on va on va tous on va tout
donner on va tout donner
donnez donnez donnez moi et il prend le
pion ces cadeaux et on sent déjà les
mecs sont sueur qua non je ne veux pas
prendre ton pions bon bah écoutez à si
on me laisse le pion je vais les garder
un finalement donc au final j'en ai
donné qu'un bon alors on va y aller avec
beaucoup de conviction là les mecs
allez on y va à fond
bon je suis pas méga confiant ça marche
pas du tout
alors ça marche pas du tout mais il va
falloir continuer
je t'aime très con ce que j'ai fait
blanc a évoqué un s'y prend on prendra
prendra prendra et on ira recherché ça
et on sera complètement foutu mais bon
pas le choix il ne prend pas part du
coup je vais placer un petit fou g4
quand même gagné un tempo sur la dame
c'est cool il a peur il baisse le regard
d'anne d2 alors comment on brutalise ici
truc si je le prends je pense va
reprendre de la dame laissa le
développent avait quand même sacrément
malin bon les mecs
on n'est plus à un pion près
on n'a jamais été un pion près de façon
il ne prend pas une nouvelle fois il
veut pas prendre les pions je pensais
qu'il allait le prendre quand même bon
c'est un pion isolé après mai mais bon à
sa place j'aurais quand même pris et on
va chasser ça un peu
mais ça ici sur les affaires qui
relèvent 5 à un moment donné alors à
faire des quatre comme ça s'y prend on
ira prendre à deux ou pas d'ailleurs ce
même patient on peut mettre le foin est
fuite
on n'arrive pas à le faire douter un
donc à faire pousser quatre ans a tenté
le cheapos qui sait peut-être il prend
et on fait fourrage de escape chipant il
voit un match écart est avec la dame
pour là on va perdre les mecs mettre le
foin et fuite
elle a bien joué on n'a pas réussi à
brutaliser kirwa chaussettes
bon ça c'est souvent pas mal comme
défense
mais bon avoir deux pions de moins et
jafar tenter des magouilles allez on va
prendre un pion là je pensais qu'il
prendrait du cavale et on va remettre le
fou en dessin qui s'est épris du cavale
ça aurait perdu je vous prends à xii
d'avoir des 3 c'était plus fort je pense
parce que ça ne permet ni enlever un
pion alors ça c'est ultra désagréable
on est tellement mal et quoi
puis on prendra son à sa tour je lai est
une tour ont des cinq jeux c'est
tellement pas quoi jouer tellement dur à
défendre je vais changer et je vais
remettre une tournée 8
je pense pas que ce soit si mauvais
d'échanger des pièces pour moi rien à me
ranger sept matches j'avais pas vu aïe
aïe aïe elle a écouté on va perdre
aïe aïe aïe bien joué et bien joué a
tenté d'arnaquer l'on ne pouvait pas
quoi notre ouverture n'a pas fonctionné
bon bah tu le fou en d5 n'était pas si
loin à verdun meuse 7
car ça ne va pas laisser pousser
on n'était pas si loin
à
on va faire dame b 3 si je pense qu'on
va pouvoir abandonner là vraiment bien
joué rien à dire
rien à dire
voir rené pas mal joué que faire baisse
par ailleurs avant les mecs
allez un autre défi on essaye de jouer
les ouvertures un peu bizarre après 3 +
2 difficile il a bien joué toute la
partie un appareil qui tout réussit à
l'arnaqué il n'a pas pris les purs il a
bien joué que faire que faire que faire
justement éclater la soirée mais là j'ai
une journée un peu trop fait quoi là
j'ai un peu trop donné d'avancé au début
ça m'a un peu too much des français 6 5
c'est quand même très mauvais c'était un
poil too much et du coup tu as bien joué
après parce que tu es c'est comme ça
nous allons aborder d'autres d'autres
défis ou pas
voyez ce qu'on n'a pas besoin en a pas
je fais des bulles est tombé c'est pas
une très bonne idée de remonter au
classement avant la reina mais bon j'ai
bien envie de tester ma souris mais bon
on remonte à 2006 c'est pas ce pas une
mauvaise chose que la fois lundi j'ai eu
quand même beaucoup de points est bon on
n'est pas quand même dans le style de
mec qui vous les arénas qui essaye de se
garder des petits classement va être
dans l'esprit de sa de montée du
classement
j'ai juste avant le temps d'enlever la
tour ça ça va être cool et on a poussé
poussé m le fourrage 3 allez on va
garder le droit de ce côté je vais me
débarrasser de tous
si je garde que les pièces mineurs en
fait est que j'essaye de faire tomber à
la souris je conçois que c'est une bonne
idée de garder les points auxquels j'ai
temporisé
je vais partir par là parce que si j'ai
change ça contre ça après je ramènerai
ça ici et ça va le faire
ah ok
c'est exactement ce que je voulais ok
next non mais c'est vraiment plus
agréables avec la souris est vraiment
pas mal cette souris peut-être mais très
inquiet va pousser
algérie de faire ces 5
quel genre de faire un truc risque et
haut risque et skipper des trucs avec
fou prend et qui traîne mais en jupon f5
et je m'en prendre à sa tante du
cavalier d'ailleurs comme ça je sais pas
ça j'étais sûr qu'il allait faire et il
va abandonner ok peut-être on adopte un
l'at on profite du classement pour
tenter une adoption at on va attaquer un
peu là bas il va prendre une fois on
sera pouvoir près move peut-être contre
on tue l'adoption à ok on va prendre la
prendre là
faut jouer plus vite mais la dame n'est
pas super bien placé
ça me fait un peu peur la foux 17
ok mais si on veut adopter on peut pas
faire deux nuls c'est ça c'est ça le dr
de l'adoption
je crois je crois que l'adoption tu peux
pas laisser de demi point tant mieux il
a fait fou des aides proposées nul
baal et rejoue quand même c'est
tellement de problèmes d adoption cette
histoire c'est tellement prêt mais
attention les tontons à chaque fois que
je vais adopter j'ai ce problème
à chaque fois que je vais adopter j'ai
ce problème tu commences à adopter les
mets qui se barre
et c'est un punk classique
vous êtes cuit 1
d'agression soir dans le chatt apprend
ici un f-15 avec rock
j'aurais dû mettre le feu en d4 direct
un peu lent pour le moment
c'était et b5 jouable mais ok j'ai pas
compris son idée là j'encaisse à un pion
je perds une calloc'h c'est un peu con
à
j'ai deux pions quand même un an j'ai
une pièce aussi on va couvrir
sortez couverts
on va pousser nickel
je crois qu'on a tous pris mon hockey
amicale aller revient ça fait 15 f
qui veut rejouer une finale
insupportable ce mec écoute se jouer des
finales on envoyait un
on va pousser les pions à fond pas trop
avancer le fou ce que toute façon
j'allais me faire attaquer alors que
j'aurais peut-être c'était bien placés
en b3 à ce fou
c'est rentré la veille à foisches cinq
échecs qui peut aider à 700 francs à
celui-là
protégez nickel et on va revenir
les cavaliers kakuta heureusement il n'a
pas vu
un truc ça va déstabiliser
ça m'a juste énormément déstabilise
qu'est ce qu'on va voir tester la souris
comment c'est d'avoir une bonne souris
rien pour ça tu avoir une bonne souris
pour pour le petit jeu le jeu dans le
petit périmètre
pas terrible à ce que je fais
ça a aidé pour le dans le petit
périmètre
33 des fous ces 4
bon
écoutez ce que je fais c'est très
logique pour le moment
mais jouer avec les cavaliers j'aime pas
ce que je fais là j'ai pas trop aimé la
b5 ça fait d'être ou de partout j'aime
pas
rim'k loches chinon avec armani échec
bon
ça c'est cool il s'est planté dans la
finale de pions moi aussi mais il s'est
planté dans mais ça aide d'avoir une
bonne souris ce cas je vous comme une
merde
là on joue comme des merdes garde
toujours les cavaliers il joue bien avec
je vais pas réussir à l'adopter lui il
joue à assez fort
il joue vite mais ok rade et chypre
ok peut regagner la tour mais c'est pas
grave ça j'ai vu mais bon c'est débile
ok il rappelait cheapos aie aie aie aie
aie pas d'adoption
la région compte exterminator et on va
jouer alors être le cas ici trois pas
d'adoption pas de chance pas de chance
les mecs c'est quand le match à la casse
à 1h du mat bobby fischer dewa 2h du mat
je sais pas mais sera pas commenter trop
tard
wade a accepté défi entre deux entre
deux tentatives de d'adoption voilà je
suis déçu je suis tellement déçue la
scala est qu'on lit mais trois armes
chimiques adverse ça faisait ça fait 7 0
quoi théoriquement il y aurait eu la
marge pour a vu que j'ai pas de défi
pour le moment on va repartir sur du
c'ur du bullet aya 4-0 donc on peut on
peut renforcer quoi on peut faire une
autre fusil d'épaulé
qui est prendre de l'espace à fond
mais en fait j'ai toujours la même
ouverture à toutes les parties quoi ça
n'a aucun intérêt
bon j'ai hyper mal jouer cette partie
j'aime être le pion h5 j'étais bête
j'ai plus de batterie
sur mon ordi et plus de batterie
ah mince et le fou qui tombe qu'est ce
que je suis mais je pense à ma batterie
eux de penser à la partie s'est
concentrée ce truc ça m'a déconcentré ce
truc de batterie j'étais pas très bien
mais j'étais mal quand même
dans tous les cas dé mons pas
l'adversaire le plus fun un jour la même
finale blanc noir et en plus il nous
arrive nous a refroidis en s'arrêtant de
jouer il est bien moindre que dans
l'esprit alors
c'est tout donner
c'est hyper mauvaise que je suis en
train de faire c'est vraiment super
mauvais mais le gars génie des arts il a
vu les deux faces prisés j'avais une
petite un peu une petite idée de pièges
quoi pour rigoler mais bon ça n'a pas
fonctionné
ok mais là ça a fonctionné prisé des
cinq longueurs il est rentré dans trop
de tactique pour lui il a trop voulu
tacty fier et volutes actifs y ait tout
le monde il s'est auto actifs y est lui
même et en plus si cet actif y est sale
sa fille l'a vraiment tout perdu 1
il a vu chuter son pion à
allez on va espérer
comme son nouveau mec assez ennuyeux
ça c'est hyper mauvais là ce qu'il est
en train de faire ce qui s'ouvre la
colonne h qui veut dire que j'ai rien
au caire
on sait pas à quoi ça sert qui a et b 4
mais bon on a fait quand même
je sais pas trop ce que je sais pas ce
que je veux faire
ben on n'a peut-être obtenu un petit
quelque chose
je voulais le fou le carrier contre le
fou c'était idiot
c'est hyper mal joué est ce que je fais
non
à aulaqi ans fém à tester tout match
c'est tout match c'est tout match que
j'ai essayé bras les faux faux faux faux
jour un peu sérieux là haut
quelle catastrophe
non mais la souris et bien c'est moi qui
joue comme une merde mais la souris et
bien si jouant en forme correcte ce sera
lundi ce sera mieux que ce sera beaucoup
mieux que les autres jours c'est juste
moi qui joue à trop tranquille en
dilettante sans mettre de pression est
donc comprennent la en premier et donc
comme dans tous les sports quand tu ne
mets pas de pression et que tu joueur
très tranquille tu joues mal c'est qu'on
a un truc ce moment là et heureusement
qui fait un peu n'importe quoi parce
qu'ils étaient complètement gagnant bon
il reste toujours bien mais il a quoi de
plus il est une tour moi je te retrouves
à tour g3 et vous prend et fils qui
menaça il veut faire d'am-dam gk donc je
vais commencer par tour 3 vous faire ton
g3 est fou prend 1,6 après ça lui
évitera d'avoir des dames d un math
voilà ce que je disais ça lui évite
d'avoir d'amener un matelas fou prend un
f6 très fort beaucoup plus fort de jouer
dans ce tournoi qui lui a évité le petit
intermédiaire
mallet
c'est pas terrible de mémoire on
encaisse et sa dame c'est un mât pour
écouter
pas trop compris ok maintenant j'ai
compris
spy who ce qu'il a fait
je suis un poil en sais pas ce que je
fais moi non plus je suis un peu perdu
qui est cher tout reprend 2,3 fou g3 et
peut-être prendre là du coup
je vais prendre prendre faire un échec
comme ça j'en fais un outil si je vais
passer la tour là il va faire un échec
non
il va il va il va se planquer
franchement il joue bien
je me paraît de l'autre côté
ok non mais sérieux cette souris pour
fly et c'est mieux on le sent
on le sent que c'est mieux
bon
écoutez
cette finale c'est pas mal du tout on va
cacher le ranger un s'évitera de se
prendre d'état d'échec
ouais ok c'est bien joué ça
on démarre une nouvelle fois
où en est constant dans la médiocrité on
va réussir à monter le roi un peu
ok on gratte ça et là ça va maintenant
ça va
ok
faire le pont
bloquez gagné c'était pas mal après
on a obtenu la bonne position salle
du coup
glissez le tour ici un échec là
ch.d
c'est bien joué
on va pas être une position dans les
ouvertures à
je déteste ça parce qu'il ya plein de ya
plein de menaces
mais tours sont super mal placé je
n'aime pas du tout où rue 8 mai bon ok
je claque du coup et je reviens avec le
tour je colle matin peut quelque part
voilà j'ai rien
by two reprend quel idiot j'ai senti en
plus ce qui est une menace et j'ai page
pas réagi
j'ai senti en plus on va voir la souris
du coup
c'est pas la souris la c - qui
regard a réussi à sauver le path mais
c'est moi qui fais n'importe quoi mais
du coup une nouvelle fois pas d'adoption
clavecin qu'elle avait quand même fait
plusieurs fois donc oui le puits pour
mixer une fille dans le chatt possible
j'en sais rien allez on se fait plaise
qu'elle prend francs des inquiets france
et 6 c'est peut-être pas bon c'est fait
plaise
pas mal ça n'aurait pu rater
séductrice qui rôdent non mal joué ça
très mal joué
très mal joué très mal joué très mal
joué 1 et qe 2
j'ai pas ce que je suis en train de
faire mais je me cherche des problèmes
ou pas
ok chopper
on va se mettre comme ça on va bien
enfermé
et on va repasser la tour ans et 7
un look est nickel
turp a perdu ont regardé chez moi je
prends le défi après joue un peu tu vois
et après on va ramasser les défis
quel français 7e reprendre là c'est un
peu moche ça joue pas mal on fasse un
temps mais ça vaut plus que 23 30 que 24
ans en bullet mais bon
allez on va faire le tour des six ont
regardé à tout au long des 8 ouah je le
prends des cheapos comme ça aujourd'hui
bon allez à
ouais c'est pas très bon ça
est ce que ça marche super clouage de
l'enfer qu'elle me ramener toutes mes
pièces pour attaquer ce truc donc si ça
marche pas je suis un peu dans le k4
aller et boum
barak laquerre
mais là je vais m'arrêter là si tu fais
une deuxième dame je matte
là je vois pas comment mater la fin de
match n'y a plus rien c'est débile comme
coût auquel tour à quatre c'est pas con
je redonne le trait à l'adversaire pour
[ __ ] la merde t'es tout reims est le
coup le plus con donc à n'a pas pu le
pré move et dames des femmes at voilà
enfin la f1 on a bien sacrifier
c'est bien on a bien joué au con
c'est cool
non mais ça une ration à la souris
ce que je joue vraiment mal ce soir et
c'est vraiment ça qui me sauve mais bon
ça permet de l'attester
je n'ai jamais testé en conditions parce
que je joue super super super mal je
vois juste rien là les ouvertures ça
affligeant enfin lancée je suis sûr qu'à
une menace mais je la vois pas
adam prend bien
j'ouvre à moi mais c'est horrible ça
mais bon la position est mauvaise
après c'est que les fous on peut pas les
organiser
mais bon c'était vraiment tellement mal
jouer quoi tellement une honte
alors peut-être reprend des petits défis
alors exterminator qu'est ce qui donne
c'était quand même une honte la partie
précédente bon ça là ça fait mieux 1
autant il hier hier je jouais bien
autant aujourd'hui
au taux d'aujourd'hui non comme quoi des
fois les jours et les couleurs on sépare
d'après ya la motivation city rentrent
en compte sept sites à fatiguer motive
mais motivation ça compense si t'as
juste fatigué tapas motivation en face
ça compense pas du tout
du coup on est quand même assez bien pas
assez bien on est très mal mais bon
c'est ce que je fais des ouvertures l'a
convié plus tard qu'est ce que je fais
en fait je sais pas j'ai que des très
mauvaise position assortie d ouverture
je fais n'importe quoi encore qui ce que
j'ai fait en fait je le 4 5 des cas
avaient fait des quatre handicaps kiev 3
des 5 et j'ai même pas pris je fais ces
trois oui mon gars mais pourquoi j'ai
fait ça en fait
23e très stupide quoi mais sûrement pour
ça que j'ai joué d'ailleurs c'est
sûrement parce que c'est stupide
bon
jusqu'ici on a joué de manière très
stupide peut-être qu'il est temps de
passer à la vitesse supérieure j'ai
tenté un petit d'alger 6 allez on tente
je crois pas que ça marche mais on va
espérer trick sa menace pas grand chose
quand même
je crois que ça perd tout de suite mais
il faut trouver une vente un peu
compliqué quoique non pas sur ok c'est
ce que je pensais or l'idée c'est
surtout reprend 1,5
il ya dan d un roi f2 que les g4 et sa
protégera mais je vais commencer par
dame prend effet cet échec je vais faire
tout reprendre 5 et sur d'âme des uns je
vais faire flouer f1 améliorera ses
quatre oies ok mais s'il a vu jusque là
fortement les mecs
le fait qu'il ait eu ces quatre là
jusqu'au bout chapeau d'avoir vu mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
je m'éclate
aïe peut-être faire perpète
il ya peut-être perpète que je vais être
le roi f10 f1 est un rêve qu à trois
tours deux dames et chez qui appelèrent
plaide à écouter peut-être on va faire
nul 1
tu crois pas qu'on puisse faire beaucoup
mieux que nul là les mecs vous êtes on
va faire nul à reims
j ai dit en plus je me suis trompé on va
écouter je pense qu'on va perdre
je pense que exterminator 444 peut nous
battre paris quand même très mal non il
prend pas la tour e cinq fantastiques
peut-être on a une chance parce que
maintenant on rentre la tour et on va
pas cacher droit incroyable incroyable
expiratoire il n'a pas pris la tour en
un coup aïe aïe aïe quel dommage
à quel dommage pour exterminator il a
encore été plus mauvais que moi à quel
dommage car elle était complètement
gagnant exterminator là dommage
exterminator tu étais pas loin on va
essayer straffi essayer de faire une
partie correcte
jusqu'à maintenant c'était pas super
alors
ratte c'était tellement pas loin un
tonton tu aurais fait d'armes
progression actuelle a gagné 1,7 et
filles c'était vraiment pas loin de
gagner
non on va développer
c'est un peu prendre quand même
tu peux t'en vouloir tu aurais dû la
gagner tu méritais plus que moi
voilà oui c'est une partie normale
c'est un peu étonnant cet échange je
vois pas trop la plus-value d'avoir
parce que le foot recasement ce n'est
pas forcément le bon fou ma foi
j'ai profité du cloud âge maintenant je
le prends le chip ou avec hk tu perds
une pièce là le carnage quoi c'est le
carnage
ce soir c'est le carnage ce soir c'est
juste du carnage
je vois plus rien quoi c'est fini c'est
comme dire à la fin de la reina quoi
c'est fini j'ai le cerveau qui est juste
hs en fait
heureusement qu'ils ne voient pas
j'ai le cerveau qui est hs les arénas
les commentaires les machins j'ai
flingué le cerveau là il marche juste
plus du tout out of service que la fin
fut cassé ou que jamais n'a en
réparation j'ai tellement de chance les
mecs en plus sur food et 6 ou prend 17
tours prend pions prend pions pranger
tour prend des six tours prend des 6 ou
prend 1,5 à la finale est gagnant mais
je n'arrive pas à voir la concentration
en fait
h4 qui avait eu six oui j'ai vu qu'ils
pouvaient faire [ __ ] en d4 et h4 je
n'allais pas dire les coûts non plus un
regard si je prends là il prend là je
prends la ja f4 donc je vais plutôt
aller pour la 4g plutôt aller prendre
celui-là du coup ça a l'air plus fort
oui là je comprends bien sûr h4 et des
six mais tu es fou prend des 4es h4 bien
qu est ce qu on peut prendre ça sur
échec aussi à la tour des six armes ok
ok gb 4 encore après je regardais pas
vraiment l'échiquier qui fait ça va
je prendre un petit coup là en premier
et après b4 enfin qui fait que ça va ça
a pas tant que ça en fait ça va pas tant
que ça allait tonton
je vais peut-être la perdre finalement
tisseyre b4 calme garder ça là
en tout cas ça vous montre à quel point
c'est important d'être concentré quand
vous jouer aux échecs et de ne pas
paniquer si vous perdez des partis parce
que vous n'êtes pas en forme ne pas dire
oui j'ai perdu 200 points aujourd'hui ou
quoi ça arrive envoyez moi aussi là je
joue a fortiori très mal
qu'ai je à les [ __ ] un pion g7
peut-être en premier
je joue a fortiori très mal ça c'est
hyper mal joué ils se coupent son propre
droit et là du coup les pions vont
passer tout seul la finale c'était hyper
mal joué cette faute en tête endroit c5f
5 3-6 6-7 6-3 des cff set où il a perdu
tout seul la finale 1 mais j'ai envie de
dire heureusement fallait qu'ils
ramènent le roi pour défendre et faire
nul
même s'il avait une qualité puis j'ai
deux pions pas saigner et depuis on
passé lié c'est très fort donc cette
finale à fallait la jouer pour faire nul
du coup il a joué pour gagner s'est pas
rendu compte du danger des pions pas
essayer heureusement la technique est
légendaire ce trafic
l'ong aux lettres langues au light c'est
ça la chanson dans les mecs night longue
imac
[Musique]
ce soir je fantastiquement mal donc et
que des mauvaises positions en plus un
salut parti sur al nahyan en quoi c'est
fini naret jimmy cliff sûrement vrai
est-ce que deux pions passé lié à deux
cas de promotion sont fort qu'une tour
ça dépend la position euros on ne peut
pas être très bon 1 de fer fou des deux
est fou et trois au prochain du coup
quand même
ben le calcul est pas
calculez pas clean de mon côté
cc je suis parti sur la chanson vous me
retrouvais plus quoi sur leurs ailes
night milonga font quoi non on reste
seize essayé je veux qu'on travaille
plus fort pour voir ce que ça donne pour
reprendre un peu confiance on va voir on
fait un petit 3 minutes qu'on travaille
plus fort j'ai pas ton défi sur audika
toile chez demander y a pas ton défi
donc j'ai envie de te dire non je vais
apprendre des filles a pas ton défi
online donc fait une variante mais qui a
oublié que le cavaly c6 revenait à la
défense allez on va se prendre un vent
va jouer un 3 0
si on trouve un adversaire
et on va essayer de bien jouer quoi ok
c'est de se réchauffer de reprendre un
peu confiance à ce que c'était
non mais j'ai un peu plus court mais
tout le genre d'échangé là cela
maintenant
quand plus coincés dans des champs de la
save
j'en peux plus
sur les san jose sharks et à 5 pour
laurent
alors
on est de nouveau mal ou pas dames 1
je sais pas quel point on est mal
je fasse gaffe de pas me faire
sacrifiant le 6
mais c'est dur à jouer
j'arrive pas à faire b6 pour chasser des
je sais pas trop confiance et cavaliers
ces trois là ça me fait hyper peur je
vais parler avec le roi une fois
ce qu'est ce trajet feu j'ai peur de me
faire planter ans le 6 j'aurais
peut-être dû faire m
j'ai peur de me faire planter sur la
tête dû aller
je plombé cette qui est un peu pénible
assez durs à jouer avec les noirs ça
qu'à radio 5 c'est hyper chiant aussi
même carrière si c'était vite apprendre
vous prendre six ou pas parce que
ok je vais chasser une fois maintenant
je vais profiter qui est plus pur à 6 en
l'air
je vais aller changer les dames
ok là j'ai pu me réactiver
kembs en restant dû
j'arrive pas à trouver de coup là
c'est très mal joué
patiemment le coup mauvais mais juste le
timing mais c'est dur à jouer ception
isolé où l'adversaire à de l'activité je
suis me redirigée vers son pion des 4 je
suis mal autant 1 c'est le problème
puis elles sont pas si mal placé
bizarrement si je peux faire tour des
six tours des 8
j'ai ça en l'air aussi
je l'attendais 8 mais je suis pas
convaincu j'ai peur de ce pion
question et fourrages 5 peut-être après
justin c'est la merde
stand u15 face dam des trois non il fait
pas je vais cavaliere 4 quand même qui
va être violent
mais qui n'a pas fonctionné
ok alors qu'arrive trois matches et il y
aura donné une revanche parce qu'on est
correct c'était chaud on se fait dominer
qu'avant toute la partie on était mal on
s'est fait dominer 24-14 espace pas
grandiose à de notre part
on se fait bien dominer
alors à petit en dessous c4 j'aime pas
trop cette variante
je préfèrerais f2 méfier des trucs
moderne je vous sais 4 maintenant mais
c'est censé être mauvais un yes et
surtout prendre 3 il ya peu ces dames
astro dame f3 ou ou autre chose et là
dessus ce doit être cavaliers c3 d'un
prend b2 et qu'il y ait des cinq
j'imagine je connais pas du tout ça
si je prends qu'il fait d'amd de jeu
karim qui je vais prendre une fois je
sais pas trop là je suis un peu
interrogatif
faire à 3 10 essais sur dame prend b2
qui et b5 apu d'amd quatre échecs et du
coup je me laisserais tourbe et un
hockey et que sur dame prend l'idée a
toujours payé b5 et je protège l'option
des 4
ok maintenant le problème c'est que sur
roc affoué trois échecs rouach un prix
en d4 et sur dam des trois dames prend
rock
ça me parait jouable pourquoi faire dam
des trois incomber de rock qui on va pas
dire dans de bonnes conditions et dans
les conditions acceptables
je vais prendre son pion mais je vais
quand même faire voir qu'un dans tous
les cas si je peux messi fait tour g8
ferait soir ouais enfin je voulais faire
clic droit
je voulais pas jouer en f1 mais ok avec
l'idée tour j'ai un héros apprend g1 et
me planquer mais j'aurais probablement
pas fait ça si j'avais eu possibilité de
jouer autrement
ok je vais tenter eux 5 qui est assez
risqué pour jouer dans trois sets
ce qu'aime une double attaque
et s'il gagne son fou de cases noires je
pense que je respire un peu ok il a ça
est bien évidemment
mais c'est un problème
j'ai quand même fait retour j'ai un tour
eiffe 6,3 g 2
qui est points 4/5 très fier
mais c'est un gros problème
d'un pro d2
ça c'est le coquet j'avais pas pensé
je n'ai plus de temps
qu'ils aient eu deux jours un peu tout
colmatée
pression est tellement compliqué
j'ai vraiment plus de temps quoi
faire un échec très désagréable
la position de malade mental ayada
meurent et cheikh guèye tom price is a
gagné mais là ya d'abord un échec et non
il ne voit pas je vais revenir là
j'aurais dû jouer plus simple je me suis
compliqué la vie pour rien
pai adam grand dam ils ne voient pas
à
oh non si nous a fait tomber aïe aïe aïe
on est tombé mais c'est dommage en fait
j'aurais dû prendre ici en âge si c'est
bizarrement la partie est complètement
tournée tu vois je fais tourcoing et
sète d'incroyables si ça suffisait c'est
marrant à leon centre et une dernière en
trois minutes c'était cool c'était
marrant mais il a pas mal joué un
policier n'était pas top mais un i see
where bref un du coup en fait je vais
faire un 5
mais tant que je voulais montrer avec la
flèche et je me suis retrouvé à jouer
dommage
je voulais prendre du canal évidemment
bon sens aurait rien changé j'aurai tout
est changé quand même
voilà
ça me paraît pas mal ça précédent on
veut quand même beaucoup mieux que celui
là
qui a eu cinq super bien placé
indélogeable
pas faire
fixer son clan g4 ça va être bien ça on
va aller tourner vers la barre moment
donné
je met le rang 1 5
maintenant cavalier ici s'ajoutent à
créer ça je vais faire peut-être c4
après
que je faire pays 6
ah ok logique veut que je prenne une
fois
alors où est ce qu'on va avec nos pièces
c'est pour dire par là bas mais je sais
pas exactement où je vais pour le moment
je te l'année chaque ici
et on a poussé on va échanger un pion
je pas sûr que c'était bien je il
laisser ce contre jeu là éventuellement
j'arrête mon cavalier là pour éviter ce
contre eux je vais pousser mes pions
carency je rêve 4 ça va être bien
je venir attaquer le pion ici ok c'était
pas une mauvaise idée ça me met le
français a eu avec laurent des 6 et le
cavaliere en c6 d'aller prendre le fury
c'est fini
faroy c3f 5,5 quand même
hélas en zigzag
en faire une dernière des der
les soirs où je compte quelqu'un de bon
ils cèdent pas mal juste regard et son
profil mais peine à hollande partir
alors ce que ça donne
alors ce truc
dans la trompe aux parois toujours rien
ne se fera en fou et 6 des cinq mais non
affaire à trois récits tout cb4 qu'elle
arrange ignore jusqu'à un certain moment
donné c'est pas très dangereux au québec
quatre ils laissent pas faire alors ce
que j'ai bien envie de faire c'est de
rentrer dans cette finale l'a peut-être
même si c'est pas si clair
justement à cause de ça
justement à cause de ça alors pourquoi
parce que le truc c'est que s'ils jouent
kf4 peut-être avec b 3 mai vers un
retour à 2 mais cavani f4 j'aime bien
l'idée c'est que son fou doit vraiment
venir en russie ou en racisme en a6 sera
moins bien placé
ouais mais je n'arrive pas à faire ce
que je veux j'arrive pas à faire ce que
je veux
quels effets retour c'est un pour le
moment
j'ai fait froid
ce
je vais pas réussir à échanger les tours
en fait
bah je pense surtout à de fer torah et
surtour d2 qui essaient 3 c'est tout le
fond mon idée j'aurais pu attendre
conclure mais auquel joue pas mal là
je vais me prendre comme ça s'y prend à
deux jeux l'enferment suis sûr
qu'est ce que j'ai raté qu'est ce que
j'ai raté
rien à rien rater du tout à la fois les
choper le pion à 5 pour aller faire une
dame
ces plantes d'un cacique classique quand
vous avez une qualité de plus
on n'a pas vraiment de bonnes cases pour
ces pièces-là j'ai plus de temps à jeu
par le pur à 5 vêtements j'ai pas assez
de temps pour gagner ça je m'aime la
perdre en fait je même finir par la
perdre
arias fou des gaffes ou la tour c 4 aïe
aïe aïe allez dernière revanche mais bon
c'est dommage que j'ai bien joué j'avais
bien joué en fait la partie on met lass
n'était pas évident techniquement à
finir j'aurais dû jouer plus simple
faire à six tours à huit à sept et
enlever la tour et j'aurais dû jouer
plus simple je me suis un peu casser la
tête
mais voyons pas de revanche
bon en fait une dernière j'ai envie d'en
faire une dernière messe d'hommage que
c'était là j'avais bien joué le truc
trouver truqués et ses 3 pour échanger
toutes les pièces que le truc c'est
qu'il ya plus de tours après je peux
faire un plan comme ça cavalia 2 qui est
ici inquiets des trois quilles français
5 essais imparables et du coup c'était
vraiment bien joué moi jugé utilisé
beaucoup de temps pour jouer ce truc là
et après jusque là c'était bien joué en
fait on reprend à 5 tours à cette a5 est
juste là de pousser cet ours et huit
souffrent à 5 que j'ai raté mes mais en
fait si j'avais continué pas raciste je
suis quasiment sûr que ça gagne puisque
va faire préfère f4 j'aurai toujours
cavalier e 4 il va devoir jouer un coup
de fouet puis je vais quand même prendre
ici
du coup il prend je le prends il prend
je prends et après j'ai un bon piont qui
passent s'arrêtent faire une belle
partie voyons fier content stioui on se
parle adversaire le plus fun en fait
j'aime pas je continue mais j'ai
toujours la même chose ce chien moi
aussi un petit peu mais lui plus
sympa des parties très intéressante
enfin je veux dire la force
ghellab steve venir je sais pas j'aurai
toujours la même chose fait des parties
intéressantes j'arrivais toujours la
même chose et puis toujours les mêmes
plans toujours les mêmes trucs
après ce qu'il fait le fait pas mal hein
la roja même si tu vas riton jeu ou quoi
ils jouent toujours plus ou moins la
même chose
très stéréotypé en glide s'apprend
longue je sais pas mais très stéréotypé
après quoi qu'il se passe je fais pas ta
me prends c'est ce que je veux garder le
contrôle de sa n'est pas lui laisser qui
décale je veux un peu me développer
après quoi que tu fasses ils jouent leur
matelas renard n'a quoi ce cas une
nouvelle fois il se fait dominer un
nouvelle fois hélas pion de moi
et il est mal dommage la partie
précédente can
je mettrai en réussissent
je suis pas convaincu de cailloux 6 mais
bon je vais les prendre en c2 et pas
m'embêter avec un cavalier qui revient
ça c'est bien joué de sa part ça c'est
bien joué
très bien joué même il veut s'en prendre
option eps vii jeu pas très bien ce soir
j'arrive pas à manta à contenir
l'activité de mes adversaires
il place ses pièces pour m'attaquer et
c'est chiant
il place ses pièces pour attaquer à fond
c'est hyper chiant
ah mais c'est bien joué après étendre
son va tout mais bon c'est chiant
je suis fait arnaquer l'enjeu le faire
arnaquer en ce moment
en ce moment je veux faire n'acquiert
c'est assez effrayant mais bon
toutes ses classes à qui reste en prise
je crois qu'il menace rien mais va
tenter d'arnaquer encore et encore aya
prise prises et 17 et d5 et des 17
bah y'a juste dame prend moque et je
vois plus rien et qu'il est temps
d'abandonner
non mais je vois rien aujourd'hui je
savais que j'allais me faire arnaquer
aïe aïe aïe bat une nouvelle fois des
complètement dominés 1 mais ok si j'ai
raté un truc comme ça faut juste faire
pai avait aussi prisé prise j'ai pas vu
la dame mais juste tour des huit tours
des saletés et ça gagne
mais oui j'ai du mal à voir les
tactiques en un coup aujourd'hui un peu
comme hier soir bah écoute et j'espère
que ça va revenir et à et voilà ces
périodes comme ça et que voilà vous êtes
bien amusé n'a écouté que faire j'espère
- gaffes et demain et où vous lundi et
bientôt les mecs ciao ciao